atom shift openly lied to the American
public he put America
for four years
through an impeachment that he knew was
a lie if you got the briefing I got from
the FBI you wouldn't have swalwell on
any committee
Democrats ready to go to bat for Adam
Schiff and Eric swalwell by pushing for
The Not So dynamic duo to sit on the
powerful house intelligence committee
some things speaker McCarthy has
promised to not let happen Democrats are
most certainly going to lose the fight
since McCarthy has the unilateral power
to be to boot them but Adam Schiff isn't
backing down
if McCarthy Williams this will somehow
stop me from uh pointing out when they
abused their power when they endanger
the country uh it's not going to stop me
at all uh and I will simply work with
leader Jeffries to find new ways to
continue holding them to account
remember the last time Schiff LED an
investigation is lies are the whole
reason he's kicked off Intel to begin
with I think there's plenty of evidence
of collusion or conspiracy there's ample
evidence of collusion in plain sight and
that is true there's clear evidence on
the issue of collusion
and Republicans are concerned Eric
swalwell's cozy relationship with
suspected Chinese spy Fang Fang has
compromised him
okay so in 2021 the Democrats made a
decision to expel Marjorie Taylor green
and Paul gosar and the Republicans said
don't do it because you're creating a
precedent here this precedent if you're
going to have to eat it if we ever win
in in Congress and so now we've got
McCarthy saying you know what shifts
wall well and ilhan Omar we're not going
to put them on the Committees is this
how about you what's good for the goose
is good for the uh was the Sheep good
for the Sheep what's good for the goose
the goat good for the goat I would
totally prank them and tell them they're
still on the committee and just change
the meeting times send them to other
places why why would you indulge these
people the problem with these the the
the the two uh not so much Omar she's
got her own set of problems they always
seem to care more about their own selves
than they cared about America they're
always chasing the media Spotlight uh
they were Craven opportunists which is
why shift livestock so much it's because
you ended up on TV more and of course
well the only committee he should be in
front of is one exploring natural gas or
maybe should be behind it
on in front of it but anyway uh yeah
putting putting a shift on the
intelligence committee is like putting
Jesse on a modesty committee
all right well Jesse I would share it
yeah
is it is it team Jeffrey's clueless he
says it does not serve as precedent or
justification for the removal of Schiff
and swallow given that they have never
exhibited exhibited violent thoughts or
behavior but having an affair with a
Chinese spy is no problem violent
thoughts
I think Schiff wanted Trump hung as a
traitor and if you compare Santos
to Schiff both are liars which lies did
more damage to the country yeah Santos
lied about being what like
cross-dressing or like working for
Solomon Smith Barney okay that hurt
nobody that hurt nobody except Nassau
County Republicans Schiff put the whole
country through a ringer I mean the
people in jail all based on lies swallow
well is supposed to be on the Intel
committee got honey trapped
permission to use an analogy that would
be like putting a Quaker on the armed
services committee it makes absolutely
no sense Quakers are non-violent judge
no stop if I was a member of Congress I
would assume that anybody that was
trying to sleep with me was a spy you
should think that way because no one
would otherwise
so and that gives you a great
opportunity to have your staff
investigate your dates you just run
background checks on all of your dates
before you guys go out to dinner and if
she's not a spy well good you know
everything about her but if she is a spy
dates canceled and that's what swalwell
should have done now Omar who cares who
cares if Omar's on the Foreign Affairs
committee I do you know what
because they're still going to send
money to Israel she's in the minority
she's going to get no juice and I want
to see her on Foreign Affairs because
she says silly things we put it on Prime
Time yes all right I'll ask you this
does does Hakeem Jeffries have the same
incriminating information on swalwell
that McCarthy discussed or is he
choosing to just ignore it
so this thing would swallow well and
ship and what you said from the outset
that I think uh Greg may have said that
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander I don't think that members of
Congress should be taken off in any
committees the Santos matter they should
unseat him but if he's a member of
Congress they should put him on on a
committee and I don't think you should
be able to object the shift in the small
world if the standard for not putting
someone on a committee is something you
just you disagree with the guy or woman
or you believe they were wrong about a
certain policy outcome there would be
nobody on committees in Congress if that
if that were the case three swalwell has
not been charged with anything I've
heard I've heard speaker McCarthy unless
he knows something that's not been
shared in the public sphere he says that
that Eric swalwell could not get a job
in the public sector if he needed if he
needed a background check how could he
serve or Security check how could he
serve on intelligence committee I don't
know what he's talking about he may have
something and he should share it but
Eric swalwell you can share it he has
not been the point no but but then he
shouldn't be sharing it at all then he
shouldn't be saying what he's
he's not been charged with anything or
convicted in the land that we live in
and the schools that we went to and the
thing that we studied you can't hold
something against someone because you
think that is the case but you can't
share it so I don't know what the
standard is here they should not have
kicked those other people off in the
last Congress and they shouldn't
disallow unless they can show there's
criminal activity he's been indicted to
pull over and let Democrats have their
way with that and let me tell you the
stuff that I would I would apply I like
the good for the goose good for the
ganders all right
I hope my kids are not watching Uncle
Jesse say that yeah Dana Dana you can
finish this up and the bottom line is
they didn't have to start the precedent
but they did so turnabout is fair play
and also the house goes it flips back
and forth quite a bit this goes back to
even when Mitch McConnell told Harry
Reid if you change the standard on the
judges you're going to end up with more
conservative judges and now you have a
supreme court that is conservative
leaning and it ended Roe v Wade that's
exactly what Mitch McConnell told him
that's exactly what's going to happen
when they kicked off Marjorie Taylor
green and gosar and you could you can
agree that what they said was
inappropriate and awful and terrible
it's a horrible right because you could
say that but you could also say but if
you kick them off we're gonna be in a
position to do that to you now McCarthy
has a narrow majority and now he already
has two Republican women uh spartz and
mace saying look we believe in the
principle as Harold just said that you
shouldn't kick anybody off but the
Democrats couldn't even get a unanimous
consent to criticize Omar for her
anti-semitic remember that comments if
you remember the other thing I would say
is this I didn't refrain from
criticizing good I know but you weren't
in Congress meaning meaning that like
they couldn't vote yeah you weren't in
Congress write that down
um my last point this is also a gift to
Schiff why he's running for Senate in
California and how is he going to get on
air every night and raise money
uh it's going to be by getting up there
and saying look how mean they're being
to me how outrageous it is and he's
going to get on TV every night raise
money and run for Senate of California
wow
all right hi winner Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now